bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
rami chatte célèbre militant egypte aux
palestiniens qui a passé deux ans et
demi en prison en egypte il a été libéré
début janvier merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui merci de votre
invitation
en egypte vous étiez à la tête du
mouvement boycott désinvestissement
sanctions le mouvement bds en juillet
2019 vous avez été arrêtés accusés
d'aider un groupe terroriste
et vous avez été ensuite jetés en prison
mais jamais formellement condamnés c'est
tout à fait exact je suis un militant
militants politiques un défenseur des
droits de l'homme et pour moi que ce
soit ma participation à la révolution de
2011 où ma participation à la fondation
du mouvement bds en egypte il s'agit là
de différentes formes de résistance
civile résistance non violente contre
l'injustice sous toutes ses formes mais
pas de terrorisme n'ont bien sûr pas
terrorisme c'est le type de cocktails
d'accusation que le gouvernement
égyptien oppose à toute opposition à
tous les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme les avocats tous types d'acteurs
pendant les deux ans et demi qui a duré
l'anc est entre guillemets qui m'a visé
j'ai été interrogé qu'une fois pendant
45 minutes et on m'a principalement
poser des questions sur
mon opinion de la révolution pour qui
j'avais voté à l'élection présidentielle
lorsque j'ai demandé ce que cela avait à
voir avec les allégations à mon encontre
on m'a dit que cela faisait partie de
l'interrogatoire que j'étais soupçonné
d'appartenir à une organisation
terroriste et quand j'ai demandé quelle
organisation terroriste est ce que vous
pouvez me dire le nom de cette
organisation
on m'a dit que ce n'était pas possible
donc alors pourquoi à votre avis quelle
était la raison principale vous devez y
avoir réfléchi pendant vos longues
années de détention
malheureusement depuis sept ans
l'egypte
fait face un phénomène en pleine
croissance et n'autorisent aucune voix
dissidente il n'y a
qu'une voie en egypte qui peut
s'exprimer celle des autorités tous ceux
qui parlent de questions économiques
sociales et politiques sont jetés en
prison
oui je suis un militant je continuerai
de l'être je continuerai de défendre les
droits de l'homme l'autodétermination
des palestiniens et oui et j'ai ma
participation aux événements de 2011 au
mouvement bds
mon opposition très virulente à l'accord
du siècle de la trump a donné un
prétexte aux autorités égyptiennes pour
m'arrêter vous pensez donc que c'était
cette raison oui bien sûr mais on ne m'a
jamais dit jusqu'à ma libération
jusqu'aux négociations sur ma libération
j'ai demandé pourquoi est-ce que j'ai
été arrêté personne ne m'a jamais
répondu on m'a dit cette décision vient
d'en haut aucune idée quelles ont été
vos conditions de détention
alors il est clair que j'ai été mieux
traités que d'autres personnes vous
n'avez pas été torturé non je n'ai pas
été torturé à part le fait qu'on m'ait
menotté qu'on me bander les yeux quand
même noter un mur pendant trois jours et
puis une deuxième fois à la fin de mon
séjour en prison à part le fait que j'ai
été jeté dans une pièce de 23 mètres
carrés avec 18 à 32 autres personnes
avec des toilettes qui consistait à un
trou d'un mètre sur un mètre avec une
douche froide au dessus une pièce
infestés d'insectes de toutes sortes
sans accès aux soins médicaux avec
énormément de mauvais traitements mais
ça ce sont de bonnes conditions
comparées à celles qu'ont connues
d'autres personnes qui en plus de cette
est victime de nombreuses tortures et
d'humiliation jebsen du calibre de
prisonniers trouve-t-on en egypte ont
dit que le régime d'abdel fattah al-sisi
s'en prend aux frères musulmans et à
leurs sympathisants
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez
observé
pas du tout alors oui dans la prison
dans laquelle je me trouvais il y avait
quatre annexes différentes et dans l'
annexe où je me trouvais il avait une
annexe pour les membres des mouvements
des droits civiques des membres de
partis d'activistes défenseurs des
droits de l'homme des avocats
il avait deux annexes pour les personnes
qui étaient proches de mouvements
islamiques frères musulmans ou autres
mais oui avec le temps et notamment
lors de la dernière année la composition
a changé et il y a eu de plus en plus de
personnes qui n'avaient aucun lien avec
ces mouvements qui de fait était arrêté
détenu arbitrairement et cette personne
était devenue majoritaire il ya des
centaines de personnes qui ont été
arrêtées parce qu'un agent les arrêter
dans la rue à vérifier leur téléphone
portable leur compte facebook et a
trouvé une blague une publication
parfois une simple mention j'aime c'est
suffisant pour être jetés en prison
accusés terroristes
franchement de toutes les personnes que
j'ai croisées en prison que ce soit des
proches des frères musulmans du
mouvement des droits civiques aucune
personne n'avait été arrêté pour des
crimes violents simplement pour des
opinions pour des propos politiques et
c'est inacceptable
fritz avait été libéré grâce aux efforts
continus de votre femme française
vous avez également reçu le soutien du
président français bien qu'il y ait eu
des controverses selon lesquelles il ne
poussait pas vraiment celle ci avoue le
libérer et d'autres soutiens d'encore
cependant la manière dont vous avez été
libérés soulève quelques questions parce
que la libération a duré plusieurs
semaines puis vous avez été envoyées
tout à coup à mal par avion en jordanie
et nous des représentants de l'autorité
palestinienne vous ont dit que vous
deviez aller à ramallah la capitale
administrative de palestine alors que
s'est il passé les égyptiens ne voulait
pas que vous vous rendiez en france
pour commencer oui c'est exact il ya une
campagne mon épouse mais mais agit
brillamment elle attiré l'attention de
nombreuses personnes du monde entier
elle à rallier des députés du parlement
européen du parlement français et du
congrès qui m'ont soutenu des
dignitaires des partis égyptiens des
particuliers venant du monde entier on a
pu attirer enfin l'attention du
gouvernement français qui a décidé
d'exercer des pressions pour que je sois
libéré et j'ai remercié monsieur macro
et jeu
leur fais ici car il a joué un rôle
déterminant mais oui d'autre part je
l'appelle lui et les autres pays
européens à agir davantage pour libérer
les soixante mille prisonniers restants
on ne pas les libérer un par un il faut
d'autres types d'actions pour mettre un
terme à cette crise des prisonniers et
oui enfin le jour de ma libération et
dans la période qui a précédé ma
libération nous avons négocié on a des
gosses et le fait que je devais renoncer
à ma nationalité votre nationalité
égyptienne vous avez été pensé à le
faire n'est pas le choix
oui j'ai dû le faire je n'ai pas eu le
choix ils ont dit à tout le monde y
compris la délégation française
qu'il ne libèrerait pas si je ne
renonçait pas à ma nationalité et c'est
un cas évident de chantage pour
quelqu'un qui est en prison et oui
ils m'ont promis d'abord que je pourrais
me rendre en france pour retrouver mon
épouse est ensuite que je pourrai
récupérer tout ce qui m'avait été
confisqués illégalement à mon domicile
on ça n'a pas été le cas enfin au cours
des derniers jours j'ai été victimes de
disparition forcée on m'a amenée aux
services de renseignement général
j'étais aveugle et menotté et à partir
de là j'ai été jeté dans un avion j'ai
rencontré un représentant de l'autorité
palestinienne
le plan c'était d'aller à ramallah
dois ajouter que votre père hanna lille
jade et un haut responsable palestinien
bien connu
mon père
m'a énormément soutenu
il a fait de son mieux et l'autorité
palestinienne a appelé à de nombreuses
reprises à ma libération mais ces appels
sont restés vains enfin ce sont les
pressions internationales et françaises
qui ont mené à ma libération il voulait
m'envoyer à amman pour éviter que la
france ne récolte les honneurs liés à ma
libération et j'ai insisté sur le fait
que je devais à paraître en france et
qu'il fallait rendre hommage à ceux qui
m'avaient soutenu et je leur demande
d'agir davantage pour la libération des
prisonniers parce que l'idée j'imagine
était que vous deviez renoncer à votre
nationalité et vous taire
alors cela ne m'a pas été dit pendant
les négociations
on m'a pas dit que je devais me taire
mais j'ai compris qu'au bout du compte
après ma libération on voulait m'envoyer
amman en espérant que je rejoindrai
ramallah et que là je serais arrêté par
les forces d'occupation israéliennes
aient empêché de quitter le pays que
c'est l'art permis de m'enterrer pendant
quelques mois sans exposition sans
possibilité de parler de ce qui m'était
arrivé donc il voulait que je me taise
et oui après ma libération à mon arrivée
en france j'ai reçu des menaces on m'a
dit qu'il fallait que je me taise mais
je ne le ferai pas et contre votre
famille oui malheureusement j'ai une
fille une soeur de nombreux membres de
ma famille qui se trouvent en égypte et
je suis inquiet pour leur sécurité
j'espère que mais vous refusez de garder
le silence je ne me tairais pas que se
passe-t-il en egypte est ce que la
situation soit el fattah al-sisi dire
que ce sera au cas pour les prisonniers
politiques
malheureusement oui
les égyptiens ont mené une révolution
aux belles et pacifique
c'était il ya onze ans demander la
liberté le droit de vivre du pain de la
justice sociale le droit de vivre dans
la dignité mais malheureusement voilà ce
que le régime à tirer de tout cela il a
dit que la révolution avait été menée
par des militants donc il fallait le
jeter en prison qu'elle avait été menée
par des ong des défenseurs des droits de
l'homme donc il fallait les empêcher
d'agir confisquer leur argent les
empêcher de voyager qu'elle avait été
menée par des responsables politiques
dont qu'il fallait détruire les partis
politiques nouvellement créé qu'elle
avait été menée par des gens qui
communiquait sur facebook sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il fallait les
empêcher cela qu'il fallait surveiller
et arrêter tous ceux qu'ils publient ou
qui font des commentaires
malheureusement le régime n'a pas tiré
les bonnes leçons les égyptiens demander
la liberté il demandait de la justice
sociale c'est ce qu'il fallait améliorer
malheureusement la situation est bien
pire qu'avant
d'evreux
ce qu'ils ont appris c'est que la
communauté internationale peut être
amadou et en libérant parfois un
prisonnier connu pendant que les autres
restent en prison en proposant de
coopérer pour lutter contre le
terrorisme en achetant des armes et cela
a fonctionné
malheureusement ça a fonctionné c'est ce
que j'ai dit au parlement européen il ya
deux jours il s'agit d'une politique
très court-termiste de la part de
l'europe
l'europe a intérêt à entretenir des
relations à long terme avec l'egypte et
le monde arabe il faut mettre un terme à
la logique de l'occupation de la
dictature c'est une mauvaise logique
cela ne permettra pas d'avoir une
relation durable
cela confrontera l'europe à un afflux
d'immigrants un afflux d'extrémistes et
cela a un lien avec la violence et cela
ne donne pas une capacité à d'investir
d'avoir des relations pérennes sur le
long terme ou même d'assurer la sécurité
la méditerranée où s'approvisionner en
gaz et en pétrole auprès d'egypte et du
monde arabe
il faut un pays où la liberté
d'expression est autorisée on peut
s'exprimer sur le plan politique on
applique la loi en bonne et due forme il
s'agit d'une bonne base pour la
stabilité pour des relations à long
terme cette relation aujourd'hui
malheureusement est axée sur le court
terme tels dégâts sur le fait d'obtenir
un contrat ici ou là sans tenir compte
du tableau d'ensemble est à mon sens la
france a l'obligation morale et
juridique
demander le respect des droits de
l'homme en egypte et elle le fait mais
je l'appelle à intensifier ses efforts
pour exercer de vraie pression pour
mettre un terme à cette crise maintenant
est définitivement rami chatte merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à cet
entretien sur france 24 merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi à tout de suite pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]